[Musica]
a chi di voi è già capitato di sentire
un suono come questo
non lo riconoscete vero
Eppure si tratta della melodia dei
nostri pensieri
della colonna sonora del nostro cervello
fu riprodotta da un team di ricercatori
dell'università di scienze e tecnologie
elettroniche della Cina che ha tradotto
in musica diverse onde cerebrali
trasformandoli in musica attraverso un
elettroencefalogramma
una risonanza magnetica funzionale e
diverse formule matematiche
affascinante Sì ma io la prima volta che
l'ascoltai pensai che si trattasse più
di un rumore che di una melodia
e mi riferisco al rumore che fanno i
nostri pensieri Quando ad esempio ci
troviamo dinanzi ad una situazione
emotivamente difficile
una scelta importante o piuttosto che
una perdita
Ma allora il punto
non è se lo sentiamo ma che significato
diamo a questo rumore
io lo definisco
melodia incasinata
e mi sono reso conto di quante volte mi
abbia fatto compagnia in svariati
periodi della mia vita
ad esempio quando decisi di studiare
psicologia mi scontrai con la mentalità
del lo psicologo che non serve che è
solo lo psichiatra è un dottore che per
gli psicologi non c'è lavoro
tutte visioni depotenzianti che non
facevano altro che allontanarmi dai miei
obiettivi
e nonostante me ne rendessi
perfettamente conto tutte quelle
credenze stavano influenzando la
percezione che avevo del mio futuro in
maniera totalmente negativa
Eppure anche un altro episodio
quando un giorno uscì con il mio cane
per fare una passeggiata
lo lasciai un po' libero in campagna
ma lui a un certo punto scappò
quando in strada e venne investito da
un'auto proprio sotto i miei occhi
il mio cucciolo morì dopo qualche ora ed
io mi sentivo completamente solo
Ecco ora alzi la mano Chi di voi si è
sentito così almeno una volta nella vita
coraggio
Ok vi ringrazio
ma ringrazio anche chi non ha alzato la
mano
perché
esternare un proprio vissuto non è
affatto facile come non è stato neanche
per me non credete
Ma concederci la possibilità di sentirci
vulnerabili e di passare attraverso le
nostre emozioni
può fare la differenza
la terapia psicologica ci dà la
possibilità di farlo ma nel tempo ho
capito che non esiste una ricetta
universale valida per ognuno di noi
Tuttavia condividere le nostre emozioni
è fondamentale
così come accade in terapia
per me lo è stato per questo mi sono
interrogato su cosa potessi fare io per
aiutare le persone a superare la paura
di chiedere aiuto per abbattere
qualsiasi stigma o pregiudizio
e ho pensato che i social potessero
concretizzare un po' questa idea in
fondo Pensateci sono già il luogo in cui
condividiamo le nostre emozioni i nostri
stati d'animo
E come lo facciamo attraverso un post
una storia un commento un semplicissimo
like
allo scopo di ricevere comprensione
empatia sostegno
ed è qui
che mi accade questo episodio grazie a
lui ebbi la conferma
polli
che un giorno decise di fermarsi a
dormire proprio sotto casa mia abitavo
proprio qui a Torino
eravamo a novembre 2020 nel bel mezzo
della pandemia
e un giorno Appena sveglio Guardai fuori
dalla finestra e lui era lì che dormiva
su una panchina faceva già un gran
freddo Perciò preparerei un pasto caldo
e lo portai giù
mi avvicinai lui ancora dormiva Non
volevo svegliarlo quindi glielo posso
accanto e tornai a casa
ed è qui che vi ho un'altra idea
scrissi questo post su un gruppo
Facebook
una community del quartiere in cui
esprimevo la mia difficoltà nel
sostenere da solo le spese per Holly in
cui chiedevo ingenuamente una mano
il risultato
Fu questo centinaia di like di commenti
di persone che si organizzavano
inaspettatamente tra di loro per
aiutarlo che mi chiedevano dove si
trovasse e mi ringraziano
e poco dopo
si crea un viavai incredibile di persone
che portavano ad Holly tantissimi passi
caldi coperte e vestiti
e lui era felice
un gesto così piccolo aveva generato un
impatto enorme
perciò mi sono chiesto che impatto
avrebbero potuto generare tante di
queste piccole azioni
e la risposta è stata
lo psicologo atipico
lo psicologo atipico è il nome del mio
progetto che sfrutta Instagram tiktok e
YouTube per ispirare alla crescita e al
cambiamento
raccontando storie di persone che sono
riuscito a trasformare grandi difficoltà
in opportunità di rinascita e in
occasione per aiutare gli altri anche
grazie all'impatto positivo della
terapia psicologica
atipico per uno psicologo intendiamoci e
sia lo stile comunicativo ma anche il
metodo che ho implementato e che metto
in pratica assieme a Manuel videomaker e
partner del progetto
ci lasciamo contaminare a vicenda dalle
nostre passioni ha comunque anche il mio
coinquilino
e partiamo sempre dallo scouting della
persona o in realtà che vorremmo
incontrare e da lì fissato il giorno
telecamere in spalla portiamo Il setting
terapeutico psicologico direttamente nel
suo ambiente chiese in una casa in una
comunità un carcere una palestra
Vogliamo ascoltare le loro storie
Ascoltiamo i loro perché nelle
difficoltà e l'impatto positivo che la
terapia psicologica ha avuto su di loro
ed è in questo incontro
E nella relazione con l'altro che accade
la vera magia che si racconta ci mostra
la sua anima fa trasparire tutte le sue
emozioni si lascia guardare dentro ma
allo stesso tempo ci consente di
guardare dentro noi stessi e ci aiuta a
crescere la telecamera per loro dopo un
po' è come se sparisse come se
diventasse invisibile invece è sempre lì
con me con noi e ci permette di dare
visibilità a quelle storie che magari
non verrebbero raccontate la nostra
benzina è far arrivare quella stessa
energia così penetrante a quante più
persone possibili perché qualsiasi cosa
tutti noi facciamo di positivo può fare
la differenza nella vita di qualcuno
Personalmente ho sempre cercato di dare
un volto è una forma alle emozioni mi è
e degli altri e da piccolo che attratto
dalla fotografia quando un giorno un
amico di famiglia vi mostrò la sua
videocamera e mi mostrò quanto per lui
quella passione fosse proprio una
necessità e disse questa frase ai miei
genitori Sperate che vostro figlio si
appassioni alla fotografia così non gli
rimarranno abbastanza soldi per la droga
ed effettivamente è andata così si
riferisce alla passione per la
fotografia ovviamente eh
Da lì ho coltivato il mio amore per le
immagini la fotografia e i video sono i
mezzi che utilizziamo per catturare le
emozioni
le persone in preda alle emozioni
attraggono ed io ero sicuro che dietro
quello stato d'animo ci fosse un mondo
da raccontare nel progetto lo psicologo
atipico esattamente quello che facciamo
Gabriele con la parola io con la
videocamera psicologia e cinema musica
street art e cura si uniscono
naturalmente e ci consentono di guardare
con punti di vista e competenze
differenti nella stessa direzione
la passione per la musica hip hop ci ha
sempre legati tantissimo ed è un
elemento portante una colonna portante
del nostro progetto Infatti raccontiamo
le storie con impostazione molto simile
a quella di un videoclip musicale ed è
tutto fatto in casa letteralmente dalle
mie riprese alla sua creazione delle
basi musicali per i nostri contenuti
e adesso siete curiosi di vederci
all'azione
qui entriamo in palestra con Erika e ci
racconta come dopo aver perso una gamba
in un incidente stradale
oggi da promessa pugile sia diventata
insegnante di pugilato
trasformando così la sua disabilità in
qualcosa di più grande
e qui siamo con Danilo
la natura è esattamente il luogo della
sua riabilitazione
e ci racconta come Dopo anni di
tossicodipendenza oggi
dedichi interamente la sua vita ad
aiutare le persone ad uscire dal tunnel
della cocaina contenuti così ci
permettono di sensibilizzare su vari
temi di salute mentale una tematica
molto seria
per raggiungere quante più persone
possibili soprattutto i giovani
e non importa se invece di un camice
bianco con un paio di sneakers o una
t-shirt
Ciò che conta è trasmettere umanità
vicinanza
valorizzare l'unicità
Che grande o piccola che sia una
difficoltà
l'importante è sempre come la si
affronta
per trasformarla
ed è questa la bellezza del chiedere
aiuto
perciò mentre tutti noi siamo alla
costante ricerca del nostro perché
e dell'impronta che vogliamo lasciare in
questo mondo
Mettiamoci tutti in ascolto della nostra
melodia incasinata perché può darci
preziosissime informazioni su noi stessi
e se non sappiamo
Che significato darle
se ci sentiamo in difficoltà
chiediamo aiuto
Parliamone
Perché c'è sempre qualcuno pronto a
intenderci una mano
prenderci cura di noi stessi
significa dare valore anche alla vita
degli altri
e vivere una vita nell'amore che tutti
noi meritiamo Grazie
[Applauso]